what started as the way for creations to
increase their bottom line has expanded
into a consumer service as well you can
get someone to buy your groceries miss
Freeman or even hang out with your mom
Jenna can make it safe but i'll be
hanging out with you oh don't judge
people love you mom and even break up
with your boyfriend for you i'm bob from
dr. breakup Jena Friedman says really
nice but she just wants to be friends
have a great day
she broke up with me best $30 i've ever
spent
when it comes to providing outsourced
labor india is king with a large
english-speaking workforce willing to
work for significantly lower wages than
the average American in 2015
India's outsourcing industry was worth a
hundred and forty six billion US dollars
with about 10 million people employed in
the IT industry alone